m
tu mens
musique danse l'après midi est animée au
but de la ravine des cabris à l'occasion
de la fête de la musique le ôb style
dampniat remède proposé un concert de ce
type en un instrument qu'ils ont
découvert quelques semaines auparavant
l'est-il pas que ce sont des gros fut
découpée dans des barils de pétrole ça
vient directement le tribunal tobago
instrument qui présente la particularité
d'être a pris facilement parce qu'il n'y
a pas besoin de connaître la musique du
solfège
c'est une
musiques de tradition orale donc comme
on a repéré sur le secteur plein de
talents musicaux dans les familles s'est
dit pourquoi pas il ya trois mois de ça
on a commencé à faire des séances tous
les mercredis après midi et pour arriver
à l'aboutissement aujourd'hui sur cette
scène pour a fait des amis
k
séances de deux heures tous les
mercredis et
à la suite de salomon des deux morceaux
donc les steegmans c'est ce joueur
qu'est ce qu'il ya chacun fait quelque
chose de différent comme comme un
orchestre
à la base c'est d'accompagnement la
mélodie et percussions tout ça donc ils
ont monté un orchestre en 13 séances il
on aura je te montre ce projet mené en
faveur du public de l'aide sociale à
l'enfance
associer les enfants et leurs familles
autour de la musique dans ce quartier où
beaucoup de familles vivent dans
l'isolément plusieurs jeunes dotés de
prédisposition naturelle pour la musique
ont été repérés et invités à participer
à ce projet la musique de la musique et
on ne savait pas qu à ce moment jouer
oui messieurs dames on a montré à me
remettre nous a montré qu'on savait pas
je vais en mettre le fait il ya
plusieurs notes du coup j'aime bien je
suis j'ai écouté ma soeur et s'en va
concerner la musique était forte ça
devient vous dansez encadrés par le
conseil départemental ce projet a permis
à ces jeunes de développer leur talent
naturel
on a quand même des assistantes sociales
on a des éducateurs on a une équipe
directive qui a pour mission de
travailler
les enfants pour la famille et faire en
sorte que on leur fasse découvrir aussi
des choses qui n'ont pas l'habitude de
connaître et puis en même temps de
renforcer le lien familial et ce
projet-là rentre bien dans le cadre de
référence démission du conseil
départemental avec une scène libre mise
à disposition du public lors de cette
action organisée par le département
les habitants du quartier ont chanté et
dansé tout l'après-midi une ambiance
propice aux échanges intergénérationnels